La Bretagne d'abord c'est plusieurs
universités vous le savez même si il y a une
université qui a une force de
frappe plus importante c'est
l'université de Rennes qui n'existe pas
encore mais en tous cas c'est le site de Rennes et
je crois que c'est important de bien
comprendre que dans le domaine de la
recherche il faut des masses critiques
donc le fait qu'il puisse y avoir de
l'excellence à Vannes, à Roscoff, à Brest
c'est tout à fait reconnu le Cnrs l'accompagne
mais il ya néanmoins un certain
nombre de sites dans lequel il ya des
masse critique suffisante pour vraiment être visible au niveau international
et donc de manière générale les priorités j'ai envie de dire c'est
un peu celles qui ont été mises en avant
au cours des différents projets qui
n'ont pas été couronnées de succès mais
ont clairement montré les capacités de
Rennes et de la Bretagne c'est bien sûr
tout ce qui a trait à la mer et à
l'environnement c'est bien sûr tout
ce qui a trait aux sciences et
technologies de l'information de la
communication, dans l'informatique, les
maths, l'électronique
et puis aussi faut pas l'oublier on a
des forces très forte en chimie. Les domaines principaux mais
comme il arrive parfois qu'il y ait des
poches d'excellence des niches
d'excellence en dehors des grands sites
on peut avoir sur un site des niches
d'excellence dans des domaines qui ne vont pas être prioritaire mais néanmoins ces
niches d'excellence contribuent au
rayonnement des sites et il ne faut pas les oublier
Le Cnrs a de tout temps
une politique de partenariat très fort
avec les universités les écoles on a je
citais tout à l'heure les presque 1000
UMR que nous avons toutes sont
communes donc comme leur nom l'indiquent
UMR Unité Mixte de Recherche sont
communes avec des universités et des
écoles et d'autres organismes de
recherche
et ici sur le site de Rennes on a une
politique très forte de partenariat c'est
pas à nous Cnrs de faire la
politique des universités des écoles à
leur place mais je crois qu'il ya sur le
bassin rennais une force de frappe qui
mériterait une visibilité un peu plus
forte et le Cnrs sera prêt à accompagner
dans les années à venir les partenaires universitaires
ces partenaires universitaires pour essayer
de faire émerger sur le site de Rennes
une université qui soit réellement
visible au niveau international
à